this morning Democrats are trying to
turn a congressional election in Georgia
into a referendum on President Trump 18
people are running for the sixth
District seat that's just north of
Atlanta the National Democratic Party is
backing a first-time candidate John Asif
the president is targeting him with
phone calls and tweets Nancy Cordes is
in Atlanta at a rally of a soft
supporters Nancy good morning good
morning and these Democratic volunteers
are getting ready for one last round of
door knocking on Election Day and you
know that the entire political world is
focused on this election when President
Trump himself tweets about it twice
before 7am for national Democrats still
stung by his surprise win in November
this race is one small shot at
redemption y'all ready to flip for 6 30
year-old John Assad is hoping a surge of
anti-trump energy will help turn this
suburban Atlanta district from red which
is blue for the first time in nearly 40
years it's a prize so tantalizing to
defeated Democrats that they've poured
8.3 million dollars into his campaign in
two months that's 18 times more than the
top Republicans have raised in this
final week he's also seen an influx in
volunteers from other states joining
forces with local w reminiscent of s
foreign actor samuel l jackson cut this
radio ad urging democrats to vote
remember what happened the last time
people stay at home we got stuck with
Trump Republicans have attacked us off
as an inexperienced opportunist resident
Trump who won this district by just one
point said on Twitter that all soft
wants to protect criminals allow illegal
immigration and raise taxes he also cut
this robocall Liberal Democrats from
outside of Georgia are spending millions
and millions of dollars trying to take
your Republican congressional seat away
from you or George's at
to any of the other candidates in two
ways aw Soph has benefited from a
fractured Republican field 11 GOP
candidates competing against all five
Democrats today in what's known as a
jungle primary do you feel more pressure
knowing that Democrats across this
country have invested their hopes in you
I feel so well supported by thousands of
years here in this community to win
outright today aw Soph needs to win
fifty percent of the vote now that's a
tall order in a GOP district but what
would be even tougher Charlie would be a
runoff in June we're all GOP voters
would be united around one Republican
candidate instead of 11 thanks Nancy